Welcome back!
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello!
Welcome in, welcome in, welcome in!
I mean the...Hi!
You like my hat?
Should I have glasses on too?
It's fine.
We're shaded.
Cute dress.
This is what I always wear.
It's Southern Bellamy.
Howdy.
Are y'all here for a cool drive?
Are y'all here for the Mint Phantom stream experience?
Well, I was just a small lass when I first got my car.
It was called a tractor.
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
Yesterday I tried to buy the same MGS Delta you got from Playasia, but I waited too long for my pay to come first.
Now it's sold out!
Oh my gosh.
No!
We'll use the money to support you through my first Akasupa future merch!
Thank you!
Oh wow, I didn't think...I didn't realize it would sell out.
Now, I know which one you're talking about.
They had the Metal Gear.
The one with the bust, right?
And I tried ordering it through...
Directly from the Konami Style Store, but it got cancelled.
And so I was like, oh my goodness, thank you Playasia for also putting it up.
Otherwise I wouldn't have been able to get it.
I'm sorry, Jay!
Thank you for the first ever Akasupa.
Thank you!
I'm really honored.
Sold out because she bought all the stock.
It was...
Very expensive.
I would not buy more than one.
Especially if I was gonna think it would sell...I didn't think it was gonna sell out.
Because it was so expensive.
Anyway, welcome to Keep Driving!
I saw this game actually when it first released on Steam.
And I was like, this seems pretty cool.
And then I saw people talking about the reviews and everything.
And I was like, okay, this seems really cool.
So I wanted to play it.
Hatsune Mike, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Minto scalping MGS.
No!
Don't lump me in with those nasty scalpers, the bane of my existence.
Maybe that's why I'm a ghost.
Maybe I died because I got scalped and I really wanted something and then I died.
And now I'm haunting the scalpers.
I'm making sure...I'm sitting on their chests while they sleep so they never have a good night's rest.
Sundress Minto win?
I don't know.
It's embarrassing.
Soul got scalped.
Yeah, we hate scalpers in this household.
So true.
Now I gotta become a scalper.
No!
You won't see me as I am right now.
You'll see...
I would disguise myself as your worst nightmare so you wouldn't even enjoy it.
You wouldn't even be like...
It's Minto sitting on my chest.
No, no.
It would be a demon.
It would be sleep paralysis Minto.
And I'm scary.
I am scary.
I am scary because you saw my...you saw my...well, maybe you didn't if you did not watch my Valentine's Day stream.
Keep driving or the car explodes.
A lot of stuff got scalped from me.
Haunt hard or...what?
What are you talking about Chuggie?
What did you want?
I'll throw hands.
I got my hands up.
Yeah!
Sure you are sweetie.
You saw!
If you didn't watch, go!
Where is my son?
Thanks for two months.
Boo.
Not scary to me.
Starboy Jack, welcome to membership and Patquin.
Welcome back.
I got my hands up.
Anyway, I don't know quite what this game is about.
Part of me is like, I feel like we'll be able to yap mid-game, right?
And I want to play as much as I can because I do have another stream later tonight, I think.
Actually, I haven't heard from anybody.
Let me message everybody and say, are we doing this?
Are we still on for tonight?
We good for tonight?
Nodders.
Doki has stream up?
Ah, ok cool.
We're on for tonight.
Doki has an inner schedule?
Ok.
Doki has a waiting room.
Ok, ok, ok.
Alright, I want to play as much as I can of this too.
I think I remember it being maybe a roguelike too, but it's basically like a...
It says it's an RPG, but it's like a driving RPG and inventory management stuff.
It feels like it will be very cozy.
The summer sprawls out before you as you're about to go on your first big road trip alone.
It's been so cold lately though.
Maybe I do need some summer vibes.
She's so cute when she tries to be scary.
I am scary!
I am!
It is pretty roguelike, huh?
It's the early 2000s.
You've recently got your license.
Oh!
I also wanted to say...
There is a streamer mode for this game, but I did not turn it on.
Because it says that you'll miss out on some cool music.
Honestly, I'd rather listen to cool music than stay monetized.
We'll keep that...
Honestly, usually if it's a thing like that, you just lose the monetization for the stream.
I'd much rather listen to the cool music and have you guys listen to it too.
Maybe we can discover something else that we...
Like a new band or something that we like.
You're young.
Take it easy.
You have time.
Is this gonna heal some people's inner child?
Driving spooky.
Sending Spotify finds.
Oh!
Is this me?
Wait, A?
Or B?
We got a sick...
We can be...
We can be not snake?
We could be not solid snake or we could be the boss.
One is handsome.
They're both beautiful.
Unmetal guy.
B?
Okay, we'll go with B.
Background.
What's your name?
Minto.
Relationship with your parents.
Uh...
What does that mean?
A good relationship with your parents will help you in a pinch.
Oh, this is not real.
I feel like I'm at therapy right now.
OSC is cool.
You have to set your playlist every time I finish playing.
Oh, I see.
What's my occupation?
Oh, starting trait.
Carefree.
Wanderlust restores one additional energy.
Okay, we don't know what any of this means.
So we can be unemployed.
Part-time mechanic, which means we're car savvy.
Whenever you restore durability, restore one more.
Okay.
Or...
A student.
Start with one skill point.
Gain a skill point when you read.
Interesting.
And there's nothing else.
Um...
Uh...
Are we in NEET?
Restores one additional energy.
I feel an additional energy means we would be able to do more stuff.
So maybe let's try for that.
And what are you bringing with you?
Mom's care package.
Which is...
Chocolate.
Jerry can full.
Bandage.
Banana.
I read that as bandana.
Aspirin and letters.
My tools.
Toolbox.
Jerry can full.
Duct tape.
Apples.
Letters.
Or guitar and beer!
This feels on brand for our character.
We're a wanderlust carefree...
Carefree Minta.
In the early 2000s.
We have a guitar.
Cigarettes.
Beer case and letters.
Beer o'clock baby.
Am I picking?
I feel like I'm accidentally picking hard mode right now.
Mint.
That's me!
For sale.
1981 sedan.
Four passenger seat.
Two passenger seat.
Average trunk.
Average engine.
Big trunk.
Muscle.
Small trunk.
Good engine.
This feels like the best of all the worlds.
But we will have to...
Really...
Space our inventory much more here.
I've never driven a truck before.
Not available.
Oh, it does say not available.
You're right.
Oh, I didn't miss that.
Or I didn't see that.
So we have to go with the sedan.
Oh, shucks.
My license!
Name.
Minto.
Parent.
Parent relation.
Three out of...
Oh, okay.
Wow.
Why is my license sharing my trauma?
Okay.
Here we go!
I will try to find a good place for me to...
As you can see, there's like some gas here.
There's a bunch of stuff on the bottom.
Maybe...
Hold on.
Maybe I shrink myself and I kind of go...
Like up here.
I'm like on the dashboard.
I'm like one of those hula ladies.
I'm a hula lady!
Aloha!
We'll try it like this.
And we'll just adjust as we go along.
So it's Sunday.
June 3rd.
10 AM.
Oh, kiddo!
Thank you for the hula costume!
It's my birthday, so I'm spending...
Building my mythical clock while watching...
Wait, you got your mythical...
Wait, you got it?
You got your...
Wait...
The block?
While watching my kami-yoshi.
Happy birthday from our favorite cosplay.
We'll really make it complete soon in the year of...
Crash-outs and karaoke.
Your undead fills our lives with laughter.
Happy birthday, Akira!
Happy birthday to you!
Oh, I'm getting blocks.
It's okay.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Akira!
Phantom Thief of Hearts!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Also, Ryan, thank you for the 10 gifted.
Above energy is best.
Right side has event stuff happening.
Oh, I see, I see.
Okay, I'm gonna shrink myself even more.
And we'll move our...
Right here.
Oh my gosh, this is weird.
I'm on the left side.
You guys will join me.
I gotta move my setup now.
Don't fall off the dash.
One second, I'm adjusting some stuff on my game screen.
I'm small.
There we go.
Oh, look.
The wind just makes me feel so like...
Makes me wanna take a deep, big breath.
You know?
Is this game gonna make me wanna touch grass?
Let's enter.
Click and drag items from your home into your trunk.
You can also shift-click items to move them instantly.
Okay.
My cigarettes.
My beer case.
Don't forget your letter.
Seems like there is one letter here from your friend.
Can I open it?
No.
Okay.
My beer case.
A case of beer.
Gets you happy and drunk.
A nice electric guitar.
Used from glove box during events.
Oh wait, I can put it in my glove box.
Look at that.
We have chewing gum, duct tape, chocolate.
Nice.
Thank you so much, Minten everyone.
My mythical came last night.
Oh my gosh!
Have fun in Japan, Minten.
Thank you!
Right-click it.
What?
This?
Oh yeah.
It says use.
But we are not gonna use it right now.
Is this my room?
Two lane.
This is me.
Oh my gosh!
I'm ruffling the hair.
You can head-pat.
That's so cute.
Sorry.
I didn't expect that.
AD.
Okay.
I got 75 dollars to my name.
And we are on...
Oh no!
Oh my gosh.
We are a bit of a speed demon.
Click the car to...
Oh wait.
Click the car to open car menu.
Trunk.
Calendar.
We got no logs.
And road map.
Whoa!
Where are we going?
Where are we?
We are in the country.
We could go to the motorway.
Read the letter.
Oh is that what you guys meant?
To read the letter...
By right-click.
I see.
New journey.
Way out festival.
Click and hold to open.
Hey!
Are you coming to the festival this year?
I heard you got a new car.
Fun!
You can buy a ticket in any big city.
It's kind of a long ways away.
But you'll make it.
Don't forget to sleep and fill up when you are low on gas.
I was stranded.
I was stranded once or twice.
It's not too bad if you have some money.
See you in four weeks!
Get a ticket.
Get a tent.
Get to the festival.
Okay.
Accept.
Oh they were not kidding.
Wait.
We have to go around.
Is this our first...
Wait.
Game of the year?
Finally.
The Oregon Trail 2.
What counts as a major...
Is Toropolis a major city?
Feels like it should be.
No?
Alright.
Let's just go.
Let's just go for it.
We are still learning the game.
We are leaving.
See you mom!
Oh.
I'm going.
You want to leave immediately.
No?
Can I...
Yes?
No!
I'm not doing anything anymore.
Track the...
Makes a peaceful humming sound.
This is a road event.
What?
Wait.
This is such a vibe.
These symbols represent the road events that are called...
Are called threat.
Each threat corresponds to one of your resources.
Each threat...
Oh.
Energy.
Cash.
Durability.
And gas.
These are my skills.
You need to use skills in order to remove the threat.
During the player phase, you can use one skill.
Turn it down just a little bit.
The dots show how many uses a skill has.
Okay.
When you're out of uses, the skill can't be used until you rest.
The bottom icons show what type of threat the skills can remove.
White star...
Cons.
That...
Apparently.
It's just a blob.
The skill can remove threat of any type.
X icons remove no threat.
Use the skill Relax and align it with the threat at the bottom to remove it.
Click and drag the skill to the threat icon at the bottom display.
Perfect!
I get an extra turn!
When each of the skill icons remove threat, you get a perfect hit.
What is this game?
When you get a perfect hit, you get an extra turn.
This means you can use another skill this turn.
Some skills have costs.
It is shown here.
So this is an energy cost.
Getting into VTubers again!
I think I found my cute ghost girl, Oshi!
Can we get a youmu konpaku outfit at some point?
That would be fun.
Thank you, Arhus!
One energy.
Go ahead and use the Have a Go skill and remove another threat.
It removes anything.
Can we just get rid of anything?
We'll get rid of this one.
Great!
Even though you've got another perfect hit, your turn will end.
You may only get one extra turn each player phase.
On the road phase, the threat with a warning icon will then attack you!
Why is the tractor attacking me?
Each threat deals damage to its corresponding resource.
There are different kinds of threat warnings.
You can hover over them to see what they do or check the full list by pressing this button.
Ouch!
What am I losing?
After the road phase, something will happen.
A new threat warning will be displayed.
You...
Defeat the road event when all threat is removed.
Nothing happens.
Okay.
All three of them!
You can escape from events by holding down the gas pedal.
Before escaping, each threat will damage you.
This is your glove box.
You can place small items in here.
Some items can be used just like skills during road events.
Okay.
Does this work?
No, it technically doesn't.
What about this?
From the glove box...
Oh, I see.
I see.
So it has to, like, align, right?
This one... The cigarettes could get rid of just this one.
And then this...
Would get rid of just one.
Okay.
The chocolate does nothing.
Oh, no!
It restores two...
Energy.
Wait!
I didn't mean to use it.
Oh my goodness.
I didn't mean to use it!
No!
I clicked it on accident!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Whoops.
My bad.
I wish I could, like, move these, you know?
Well, this is the only threat.
Let's just use this.
Wait.
We don't need to, right?
I get an extra turn.
But I don't want to waste this.
You know what?
Let's just...
We're learning how the game works.
So let's just try it.
Okay.
More attacks this turn!
I have no idea what's going on.
Me neither.
So if I tried this...
There we go!
Alright!
We got through!
Why are you attacking a tractor?
More like the tractor was attacking me!
It's fine.
We're cool.
We're chill.
We're vibing.
Another tractor!
Another tractor.
Okay.
Only one thing was...
Oh, see?
Like the chewing gum.
But it would be better to use this, maybe.
This is like a real tac...
And then...
Oh my gosh.
This is so tactical RPG.
I mean, we gotta get rid of all of it, so...
Okay.
It would be better to do that.
We'd at least get rid of one.
Where does the damage happen?
Oh, I think it's over here.
Okay.
Extra phase.
Okay!
Bottles!
Oh no!
This is not as...
As, um...
What's the word?
As Conkool Collected as I thought this would be.
Oh wait, so I can't use this one again.
Oh no.
Okay.
I can't, right?
Yeah, it won't let me.
Okay.
It's very intense.
What is...
Wait, what is this?
When you hit this threat...
Also remove...
Adjacent threat!
Oh my gosh!
We, like, actually...
We...
We combo.
Wombo combo, baby.
Who are we talking to?
Oh!
Hello.
Hey!
If you're going out on the road, you better be prepared.
You gotta have a journal.
To write stuff down.
Oh, and a music player is...
Necessary.
Music player is necessary, though.
Minto.
Very cool.
Oh!
We added a journal, rest, and music.
Oh, cool!
And then, if you guys like the music...
These are, like, actual bands, so...
Wait, do you wanna come in?
Good luck out there!
Our journal...
Right click to see details.
Oh, wow!
We can unlock new skill stuff!
I'm guessing we need two points for it.
Yeah, cost two skill points to unlock.
Alright.
Wait.
Something is...
You saw that there was an exclamation point.
Huh.
We have a rest.
Durability minus one.
Where are we, anyway?
Oh, we're, like, halfway there!
If my car had a durability...
It would be, like...
One.
One, probably.
I like how we're just in the middle of the road right now.
West coast.
That's what we're listening to right now, baby.
There might be something up with the suspension.
Oh,
we're here!
We can fill up!
Accept the gas amount and pay.
Reset the gas...
How do I...
How do I know how much?
How much...
How much am I putting in?
Oh, gas 100%.
Okay, nevermind, hold on.
Hold on, reset.
Let's do...
85%.
Look at that.
To the brim.
No, we only have $75!
We need to find a way to make money first.
A road trip with Minto would be peak?
You think so?
Okay.
We need to make money first.
We can enter in here.
What do we got?
And we can get new stuff for...
Like, look, I used my...
We can get an actual hula dancer.
Okay, I know I said that we needed to save money, but...
I know I said we needed to save money.
Remove one thread at start of road during night.
Chewing gum?
Which I think I used already.
I used their chewing gum.
Get discount at gas stations?
Coffee?
Ciggies?
Cool shades?
Save money so we can get hula...
I mean, we can get a hula dancer right now.
Does she fit in here?
Got to put her in my glove compartment.
How do I make her...
I'll set on my dashboard.
She sit like right here?
Or you can get cool shades.
What is this?
Aspirin.
Cures headaches.
I feel like that might be a good thing to have.
We have so much beer.
Protects against... Wait!
That's a car upgrade.
Wait, that's kind of huge, right?
Right click on her?
Use.
Right click to lower...
Rotate.
Oh yeah.
You should crack open a couple of cold beers and experience the average Australian's Wednesday morning.
What?
I say that as a South Australian.
There's nothing better to do in this state on a Wednesday morning.
Sending this from my car, by the way.
Good morning!
Drunk driving.
No!
We're responsible.
I'm gonna get this.
I think this is gonna be huge.
This is gonna save our butt.
I think.
It's big.
It's big, big, but I think we should.
Why would I...
Use from the... During events removes threat warnings.
But it's all... It's triple X.
The discount?
What was the discount one?
This one gets discounted.
We're spending all our money here.
This is how...
I'm trying to understand.
This... Wait, do we sell stuff?
Like, if I sold this beer, would I get 15 dollars?
Oh, I think I can sell my guitar.
And we get 50.
I see.
I'm trying to see if...
Like, this has three...
This flashlight has unlimited uses.
So I think it would be good to have...
If we're riding at night.
No, we're not gonna sell the guitar.
I'm just saying hypothetically.
If we are, you know, about to die.
But I think this would be good to have.
It's 106 miles to Chicago.
We've got a full tank of gas, half a pack of cigarettes.
It's dark and we're wearing sunglasses.
Hit it!
What's the rope do?
A rope can always come in handy.
Okay.
Doesn't really tell me anything.
Is it probably some story point or something?
I imagine.
Mint Watch Blues Brothers.
I'm a soul man.
Coming to ya.
On a dusty road.
Good lovin'.
I got a truck load.
And when something...
Oh gosh, I sang that in elementary school.
I was in a play.
And it was like one of those like...
Modern takes of a fairy tale.
But with modern music.
And they made me and another girl a blues brother.
And they were like, isn't it funny?
Because you're not brothers.
And you're not even sisters.
I was like, okay.
I still remember the song even now.
Okay.
Maybe we'll get an aspirin.
I'm trying to get like the things that might, you know, like...
Maybe we do get the rope.
But I also want the flag.
Dashboard figurine.
Let me put her in my dashboard.
Like this looks like a perfect spot for her.
Or maybe the torch.
I mean the flashlight.
Oh no, I'm starting to speak like an Aussie.
No?
Actually, do they say torch in Australia?
I know they say torch in Britain, right?
The flag for sure.
Okay, we'll get the flag.
Can't get the rope though.
We say torch too?
You do?
Okay.
We can get also...
Oh, I only have 8 dollars.
Okay, nevermind.
We're leaving.
We're done.
Yeah, we're broke.
We're broke!
Rainbow!
Is the rainbow a threat?
Why?
What is the rainbow attacking me for?
Did you grab a slushie and circus peanuts?
Circus peanuts!
Dang, my energy.
But we get extra energy.
So we're actually pretty good.
Next energy is reduced to zero.
Stop for hitchhiker or keep driving?
I'm gonna stop for the hitchhiker.
Hello!
How are you doing?
Wait, is that a red block B-21?
I used to work at a garage.
But I got so tired of repairing all those new heaps of junk.
I needed to get away.
You got space?
He's a mechanic!
Wait...
A good looking guy with a bunch of tools.
I should be scared.
But his easy manner and quiet voice puts me at ease.
Can you die in this game?
I wonder.
An ally?
Girl, you have the membership card.
He looks at my car and asks about the engine.
After a drag of a cigarette, he returns to inspecting the car.
So, do I let him in?
Right click to lower seat.
Oh my gosh, I can get more room!
We had more space this whole time.
What do I do with this?
How do I let him in?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, new.
Automatically restores one durability when you reach your destination.
Cool!
Oh my gosh, so the hitchhikers also give you skills and stuff?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Here we go.
The music is so nice.
Your car needs work.
Okay.
Sorry.
I don't have the money.
I have 8 dollars to my...
Oh, another tractor!
But we're stronger now.
You
can click on the portraits of your passengers to see their skills.
He's got that.
Maybe if we get rid of...
If I got rid of these two, then we could use his skill.
Let's try it.
Perfect.
Now?
Okay.
Oh no!
I'm still gonna use it.
Nice.
Okay, nothing's gonna hurt us though.
I'm running low on energy.
Okay.
Oh, and they gain experience?
Plus one tired.
I'm tired?
I got some skill points.
Don't forget to open your journal to learn new skills.
You can access your journal from the car menu.
Oh, and if you're out of skill uses, you should probably rest.
Max energy reduced by one.
No, I'm tired!
How do I...
How do I unlock this?
Unlock.
I'm clicking.
Oh, I gotta hold it down.
Okay.
What's this?
Oh, we got a blue tire now.
Good, good.
Okay.
Very nice.
Good job everybody.
Should we rest?
Durability minus one.
We have a mechanic.
Let's rest.
Why does that lower my durability?
I don't quite understand.
Now we're dirty!
Hitchhikers gain less EXP.
Are you kidding me right now?
I've got like no money.
There's more here.
Wait.
Oh, there's lots here.
What kind of upgrade did you get there?
Not bad.
But if you want, I can help you pick out some better parts.
I've got some ideas for how we can make her a real beauty.
Okay.
I've got a quest added.
That's right.
Can I use this?
Or...
How does this work?
How does it...
How does it work?
Can I put her in my...
Can I put this in here?
What is this for?
Enter the garage.
Okay, let's try it.
Enter.
Welcome to the garage.
You can install upgrades and customize...
Okay.
It's also the place to repair your car.
I don't want to sell it.
I want to use it.
Customize, shop, repair.
Customize.
Maybe here?
Interior.
Crocodile alligator.
I drive a Chevrolet movie theater.
I see, I see, I see.
Utility.
Oh my gosh, we got her in there.
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
Okay, this doesn't go in anywhere.
Can this?
We're making space, we're making space.
This is perfect.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Choose the type of service.
I don't have money.
Budget repair.
Mechanical system.
I don't know what any of this is though.
I think our car is not so bad right now.
Right?
Probably pretty okay.
Gets a discount at garages.
Use the glove box.
Mechanic guy will repair anyway.
It's true.
Oh, so I can access the upgrades from here.
Good to know.
Winter tires.
Uh-oh.
We're gonna need to get those eventually, right?
But we're far from winter.
I hope this doesn't turn into a national lampoon sort of vacation.
Where we get...
Lampooned?
Uh-oh.
Please place me in your glove box.
I have space.
What's in this mini-mart?
We got fresh bananas, watermelon, chocolate, cigarettes, fruit candy, carrots.
Orange!
Orange, you glad I didn't buy a banana?
Soap!
Wait, it says we're dirty.
We can use the soap.
It's only $1.25.
We're clean now.
Or we will be.
We will be.
Alright.
Nice.
Let's see if this food mart has anything special.
They have the thing that we have already.
And another hula.
And chips.
Steering wheel.
Makes you immune to the stress status?
I don't have enough money for it, but I didn't know there was a stress status.
Steering wheel sleeve.
My car is not in very good shape, so it doesn't look nice right now.
But I've always wanted to make my car inside very cute and fun.
Like have the steering wheel cover and the seat cover.
You already have an interior upgrade though?
I think you can have multiple, no?
Oh, this is roof.
Nevermind, yeah, you're right.
So it's either one or the other.
This is much better, I would say.
Than aesthetics.
Always wanted a cover.
I've always wanted a cover.
I'm a menace on the road.
Oh my god.
Oh wow, the hula gets faster when you drive.
Watch.
Hold on, back it up.
You're good, you're good.
I'm gonna get sickness from this.
So, you guys...
We must now...
Decide our route.
Maybe here, game of the year.
Wait, there is a... Oh wait, what's down here?
How do I see...
Our... Is it under journal?
No...
How do I see our missions?
Only thing missing is an Itasha option.
True.
I'm at work right now taking care of traffic signs.
Make sure to appreciate the traffic signs.
Cause someone's gotta fabricate and maintain them.
Have a safe trip and let me meet the horned lizard.
Have a good day at work.
We'll buff out those scratches.
Oh, calendar.
Thank you.
This one.
Highway star.
The mechanic wants to build the perfect car.
Gather and install the parts that he wants.
Install rally wheels, rally spoiler, roll cage...
This is my car!
Excuse me!
This guy is coming in and like...
Actually, hold on.
I'm gonna move down this a little bit.
It's a bit better.
God forbid he went through a school zone.
It's our car.
But it's his dream.
I mean, if he pays for it, that'd be great.
Does this place have any of the stuff that he wants?
Rally wheels!
Events start on rough roads.
Remove one durability threat.
I'm sure we'll come across another car mechanic garage place.
Can I make a minty Tasha?
In this game?
Probably not.
But...
Oh wait, nonononono.
We have to decide where we're going.
How do we make money in this game?
I don't want to sell my guitar!
So we could go down here.
This is the festival.
Maybe...
But then what's up here?
Two gas.
515.
445.
This one seems better, no?
There are places to work.
Oh, I see.
We just haven't run into one yet.
Select work from legend.
Oh, I see.
Does this place have work?
It does.
What places on the way have more work than none?
Hold on.
So if I click...
I'm not quite sure why there's a pin in these.
Get a ticket.
Oh, we have to go to a place to get the ticket.
That's right.
We have to go to a big city.
Maybe we go to this one because there's more stops along the way.
No?
We could get...
Wait, what's down here even?
Another place.
Okay.
But we have all this along the way too.
Maybe we'll be fine.
This place has some place to work.
We'll go here.
Wait, hold on.
What's this one?
Car shop.
Gas.
Yeah, I think we should go make some money, honey.
Or we could go here.
What's... I'm trying to see what the legend is.
Oh, garage.
Work.
Gas.
Let's go here.
Caf pub also has works in the daytime.
I see.
Let her run a bit before you accelerate.
Look at our little flag.
We have a red flag on our car.
You guys, the mobs are gonna come out.
The zombies.
Where's the music?
It's kinda spooky.
Kinda creepy scary.
Potholes.
Oh,
nice.
I was gonna use this.
Let's see.
We'll get rid of this one.
Oh, just kidding.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm an idiot.
This one.
There we go.
Nice suit.
And this one.
Unlucky.
All threat to attack.
Unlucky?
Who am I lucky?
Am I lucky?
We're fine.
Oh, I need to put in a new CD.
Oh, I see.
We're in the zone.
Gas decreased by 25%.
Nice.
That's huge.
CD.
Oh, I don't have another CD.
Eject.
We only have the crystal boys.
Oh, wait.
Night life.
Let's try this one.
I hope you guys like night life.
Vague lanes.
I didn't realize that it was...
If only they were switched.
We can use an energy.
How many more uses do I have on my cigarettes?
Oh, 12 out of 12.
I guess we'll use the free one.
Music is blasting from the car stereo.
It is a vibe though.
Just finished another semester of college.
Not done yet.
But thank you for being the unending source of joy and enthusiasm, Mirai.
You encourage me so much just by being yourself.
I love ya.
Amen!
EPM?
What is that?
Congratulations!
Another semester down, baby.
Getting rid of that actually kind of...
Didn't work in our favor here.
Ouch!
I'm in the zone.
No, I'm in the zone!
Unlucky.
Aw, man.
Dang it, maybe I should have wasted the energy.
Oh, I can't use that.
OK.
It's 1 AM.
I put the first music I purchased online on a CD and never took it out of the car moment.
Alright, so we got our garage here.
Employment office!
Farm work.
Need a steady hand at our ranch?
We'll pay well.
Cafe staff needed.
Janitor work.
I think...40, OK.
40 for 12 hours versus 45 for...
And then this is less...oh wait.
This is less energy too.
But like, we get 75, but it's 24 hours.
Cafe staff, I think.
It's the same amount of energy as the janitor.
5 more extra dollars.
We need the cash, baby.
Farm will eat all your energy, it's true.
Holy cow!
We have some chocolate.
Unfortunately, I accidentally wasted one earlier.
We are tired.
Not just sleepy, we are tired.
We could get the rally wheels.
A car jack allows you to switch tires anywhere.
Interesting.
That would be good for winter, right?
We could get the rally wheels.
Super wide.
Gain 1 armor.
What is this one?
The rally wheels removes 1 durability...I think that's pretty good, no?
If it removes 1 durability threat at the beginning?
Oh wait, on rough roads.
Oh, nevermind.
Gotta be on rough roads for you.
But it's for the mission, no?
Should we not try to complete his mission?
Rally wheels, rally spoiler, roll cage, servo.
What do we get?
Actually, what do we get if we complete this?
It doesn't say.
It's kind of frustrating.
What if it's not worth it?
What is servo?
Police spray?
Wait, we can eat Tasha in our car?
Servo is power steering.
Jerry can.
Expensive.
We can change the color of our car.
Don't do red, it'll pull you over.
One way to find out the reward, I guess so.
We get a nod of approval.
You don't have to finish the quest.
That's true.
I do think maybe having a super wide tire would be good.
I'm just so curious with the quest.
It does, you know?
So curious.
Do we want to waste half our money on new tires?
But it's armor.
But red is 19% faster.
You might have other quests, so it's up to you.
True.
Let's get the tires.
Customize.
Can I sell these now?
For zero dollars!
Messed up.
I don't get any money for it.
I should sleep, someone can please sleep.
Please go to sleep.
This is a chill stream.
You don't have to sell them.
I guess we could have a spare, huh?
But I don't...
Let me rotate it.
Let me...
Rotate.
There we go.
I'm going to put a seat down.
We can always put it back up, you know?
Rex the badger!
Thanks for the 10 gift.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
We'll do what we can everybody.
To not sell the guitar, okay?
We'll do everything we can.
Oh, my bad.
13 dollars.
It's great to chill with Minto as the hours melt away.
Ducky, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Sell the car and hitchhike.
Oh my gosh, PHC!
So close to leet.
Should we try for leet?
1550.
Exactly 75%.
Right now we're about half full.
In fact, I'm even going to go a little less.
We're going to go like 60%.
I think it's okay.
Yeah, I think that's fine.
I keep seeing someone up here.
It's kind of spooking me.
Lottery ticket?
Wait,
where did you see the cat?
Let's go gambling!
Oh, in the window.
Ah, I see.
I'm also flying out to Japan in a couple of days for 2 weeks stay slash holofest.
But I gotta say I'm pretty nervous as it's my first time out of NA.
What would you consider the most important tip for a first timer?
Oh my gosh, FLEX!
Wait, are you going by yourself?
Are you going... You're going to be meeting up with friends though, right?
If you're meeting up with friends you'll be totally...
Hot dog!
Yippee!
I had to get the hot dog.
It was a dollar.
Yeah, by myself meeting some people for a fest but mostly solo.
I go solo all the time.
It's kind of refreshing.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah, just have a safe trip and enjoy.
If something goes wrong, like if you're like, oh, I want to do this thing.
You get lost or something happens.
The time thing, you know, lots of things can go wrong.
But just kind of go with the flow with trips.
That's the easiest thing to do.
I find it, especially traveling, solo is to not have too rigid of an itinerary and just go with the flow on things.
Oh,
I just realized all the notice are all the way...
Sorry, the notice are going to stay on that side because I'm lazy.
Hot dog moment.
If only we got the hot dog.
Let's go gambling.
I'm gonna move that here and we're gonna go gambling, baby.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go to another place with a job.
So down here.
Hans Town.
Because I kind of want to go to here.
Or we could go up.
It's hard to say.
Why is... What is this?
Why is that... Oh yeah, this area too is also...
I don't quite know what it means.
Big travel tip, don't forget your wallet.
Yes, that is a... Oh, city limits I see.
That is a big travel tip indeed.
Don't forget your wallet.
Or your passport.
Which I didn't forget that.
But I did forget my wallet.
There's only gas stations from here.
Let's see, if we go to Hans Town.
There's also only gas stations for a long time.
Okay, maybe we should go up instead.
We'll go to Torli and we can head up a couple of places too.
Oh wait, hold on.
I'm an idiot.
I didn't have them marked.
Hold on.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, see, see, see.
We can go exploring and traveling.
We can go hiking.
Can we go hiking up here?
Yes.
What do you guys... What do you guys think?
Should we go to Torli or should we go to Hans Town?
Which do you think?
Hiking sounds fun.
Also, what is this one?
Oh, cafe pub.
Wait, we can work there.
Is there a cafe pub down here?
Yes.
And there's hiking.
Let's go to Hans Town.
Because I want to go to Skokopo.
Let's go.
Hiking sounds great, especially with you in a sundress.
I hope your intentions are pure.
I don't know.
Do you guys like nightlife?
Oh, sorry, I keep...
Abandoned car.
Interesting.
Wait a minute.
Is this a threat?
Why don't we just go around it?
Just go around the car.
OK, nevermind.
No, I can't use this one.
OK, we'll use this one.
Nice.
My energy!
Holy moly.
I'm going to eat the chocolate bar.
I forgot that uses a turn.
This is messed up.
It didn't work!
Why didn't it work?
Can he do anything?
Oh, he can!
Only works on the money symbol.
Groovy Jesus.
He's handsome.
And scrap.
Maybe someone wants to buy it.
We got some more stuff.
Just found a VR game called Sushi Ben.
And there's a female character who only walks on... Oh yes, I know that game!
Oh, this car can't race.
Not yet.
We're finally on the last one!
OK, what do you guys want to listen to?
We got Crystal Boys.
Shuffle.
Tigers!
Yeah, I remember Sushi Ben.
I almost tried to do like... They did like an open audition for voice actors.
Hell yeah, we're going to stop for the Hitchhiker.
Hitchhiker?
Oh.
Hey.
Can I get a ride with you?
The sleeper.
Poor guy, looks like he just woke up.
He told me he has a condition where he just falls asleep all of a sudden.
Anywhere, anytime.
At least I know he's pretty and harmless.
Why do we keep calling him pretty?
What does he do?
Gain 4 armor?
Fall asleep.
Falls asleep at times.
The first backseater.
Look!
Hey, great timing.
I just woke up.
We are tired.
We should rest.
Introspection.
F... Freak, is that a crack or some dirt on my windshield?
Pick at it with your finger.
Doesn't matter if it's a crack, it's a crack.
Pick at it.
Do it.
But what if it's a crack?
It'll make it worse.
You're driving though.
True, what if we crash?
Check it.
It's just some... It's just some snot or something.
Must have sneezed hard.
Nasty.
Night falls.
How close are we to the city?
Oh, just kidding.
We are hungry and we are tired.
Rusty's Autopilot.
Holy mo...
He's got a tent!
That's the optional thing we need.
Upgrade?
Which one would be better?
The hula girl or the groovy Jesus?
Let's sell the scrap.
Rusty is goaded.
Wait, how much is... Hold on.
How much is the hula dancer?
Wait, we even have a mechanic bobble head!
He's so cute.
Very nostalgic.
Hula girl is a classic.
So true.
We can eat the hot dog.
To get rid of my hunger.
Sell the wide tires.
But my wide tires!
Subwoofer!
GTI decal.
Purely cosmetic upgrade.
Oh, we get some stickers.
Cute.
Valentine's spray.
Wait, this is a car spray?
Good roof rack.
Adds extra inventory space.
Put things in the hot dog!
Toe hook.
Does nothing.
Exhaust pipe.
Reduce gas drained on motorways by one, but not lower than one.
More stickers.
AC.
Makes you immune to both the cold and hot status.
Cheap roof rack.
It's literally a shopping cart.
A fender.
Wow, there's a lot of stuff here.
This is kinda crazy.
I'm gonna get the valentine's spray.
Can I use it?
I can't get the hula girl off.
Check your upgrades.
Yeah?
Let's see what else we got here.
Gas station.
Employment!
Cafe staff.
The farm work.
We have six energy.
I think we'll do the cafe and then we'll rest.
The sun rises.
We're tired.
Very tired.
Sleep?
Oh my gosh.
Back to being hungry and dirty.
Let's grab like a snack in here.
This is probably good to have the drink that restores three energy.
Also makes you tired.
Wait, what do you mean?
Get more glizzy.
I wish.
Oh wait, we have glizzy.
Use.
Awesome.
And we're dirty and we have soap.
We're so good.
Chips.
Let's buy some chips.
How much?
Oh, I forgot to sell the scrap.
We can do that.
Lottery ticket.
You scammed me!
I feel so scammed from the lottery ticket.
I'm not gonna lie.
The tent.
Where can we put this?
We can make space.
Easy.
What does the beer do?
Oh.
I'm happy.
I'm drunk.
I have limited time during road events.
Dead all thanks to the 20 gifted.
Guys, I think I'm playing on hard mode.
Last brain cell.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you.
We're probably good on gas for now.
I think.
We got drunk off of one beer.
We're such a lightweight.
What does this mean?
Why is it bouncing all around?
I'm confused.
We gotta get a ticket.
We're going to game of the year.
Oh wait, no.
We're going to...
Right?
Actually, I don't remember.
Where are we?
Yeah.
We went to Hunstown.
Don't vomit.
Let's leave.
Oh, it's a cat.
I see him.
Wait, where am I going?
I think
I accidentally went in a place and I don't know where we're going.
Speed cameras!
Oh gosh.
Don't get... Please.
Oh my god.
This is perfect.
Wait, why didn't it get rid of it?
Why didn't it get rid of it?
There we go.
Perfect.
Did we get money?
You shouldn't be driving.
I'm scared.
What does this mean?
My gas!
Oh my gosh.
No, my gas is low.
Try to strike a pose for the camera.
Guys, are we about to die?
The mechanic has reached level 2.
Check out their new skills from the trunk menu.
What's your skills?
Game 2 durability.
Let's go.
Cost is free.
Awesome.
Will consume some of your cigarettes.
Energy.
I don't have any energy drink.
I only have chips.
Could sleep.
You can't until you get to a town.
It's all over for us.
I'm never gonna make it to the festival.
My friends!
Oh, stop for the hitchhiker.
Hey man.
You wouldn't... Oh, I'm not happy anymore.
You wouldn't mind driving me around or, you know, to my next gig?
I'm on this tour, you see.
And I don't have a car.
Never got a license.
The songwriter.
Change target threats warning into a note.
Need space for your inventory for his guitar case.
Excuse me, I have my own guitar.
I have my own guitar.
No, I can't.
I don't have room.
If I let him in...
I'm gonna have to kick you... Wait, I think I'm gonna have to kick him out.
Can I put your... Oh no!
My guitar!
He has a cat?
He does!
We have to...
Why is it so... Dump the beer?
It's only done us not good, huh?
It's only... It's only damaged us, huh?
Dump the tire.
My spare!
Hold on, we'll figure this out.
We'll figure this out.
Here, I'm gonna put all the skinny things.
Pick up your feet, everybody!
I don't feel like we can afford to not bring on new people right now, though.
Look at me.
You might call me a genius.
Tetris master.
Let's go!
Right on.
Thanks again.
Stoked to see you had some space for my guitar.
It was... Uh-oh, our gas is really low.
Wait, uh-oh.
Oh no!
Hold over by car!
I'm not drunk anymore.
Yes, I am.
It's all over for us, everybody.
Sayonara.
What card do you have?
A swift skill.
Wait, the thing is still going down!
Gain an extra turn when you get a perfect hit.
Wait, what do you have?
Oh my god, you're asleep.
I just lost my turn.
All hitchhikers are asleep!
Plus sad.
The hearing took 10 hours.
You were bored out of your mind.
You pleaded not guilty.
The late summer sun cast brownish shadows as the jury stared at you equally bored.
You end up spending three months in prison before making bail.
Your parents are ashamed, but happy you are home again.
Life goes on.
I had one beer.
No!
Oh, I unlocked the trunk!
I mean, the truck.
New starting loadout.
Shady things.
Ok, so we messed up that one, but...
Busted.
We went to jail.
At our first playthrough.
That's, you know...
Why am I such a lightweight?
One beer is too many, Minto.
Never drink and drive.
No!
I don't drink!
A festival.
One day we'll get to the... Failure!
Ok!
We got jailed, but we did not get failure, everybody.
Top of the world.
Hard worker.
The great race.
The cabin.
Inheritance.
Rehab!
It can get worse.
Holy moly.
Ok, new game.
Now I see why it's a roguelike.
Jail is better than failing.
We went to jail!
And we probably got a sick tattoo in there.
You know?
The summer stretches out before your memory, as you try to relive your big trip.
It was the early 2000's, right?
You had your license for a while, but hadn't decided on a car yet.
You're young.
For what it's worth, you have time.
The tattoo is that...
Is that emoji, yeah.
Let's go with the truck this time.
We'll get less...
What's the words?
We'll get less hitchhikers, but we'll have plenty of space.
Paying for my Oshi's bail.
Actually though, we had a lot of space when we folded down the seats.
We kind of had the best of both worlds with the other car.
I'm still unemployed.
I think the restore one additional energy is pretty good actually.
Nice anti-DUI PSA commercial, Mingi.
Paying for my Oshi's bail.
We're not gonna have a guitar and beer though.
Sorry.
I played on hard mode my first run.
Let's go with...
Let's go with the mom's care package.
Keep previous upgrades?
Wait, wait.
No, I did not mean to do that.
Wait.
That's so awesome.
And it's average truck.
Trunk.
Average engine.
This is the same.
It's also an average engine.
So...
Roguelike moment.
Let's take our sedan again.
Let's give her one more shot.
Don't forget your letter.
Wait, I got the stuff, right?
Wait, hold on.
Get a tent.
OK, festival.
Don't leave.
There we go.
My care package, mom!
OK, we're fine.
OK.
Let's go.
I wonder who we'll run into this time.
I didn't really get to see the point of the sleepy man and the musician man.
But the mechanic guy was good.
Something on the roadside.
We didn't get a tractor this time.
It's a briefcase?
Nice.
Wait, but we're durable.
We didn't really take any damage.
Look at that.
Nice.
Is it full of money?
I sure hope so.
It's full of...
Gas!
It's full even.
Huge.
I feel that I will have to add this band to my playlist.
It's so good.
Gas, gas, gas.
Oh no, tractor moment.
Makes a peaceful humming sound.
What is this?
Protects you from one attack.
Oh, it's the armor!
Disappears after the event.
The power S.
Nothing happens.
If only these were switched.
More attacks this turn.
Why is he so threatening?
Scary.
Oh, I realized we don't have our hitchhiker guy, so we don't have it anymore.
We don't have the blue attacks right now.
Something on the side of the road.
Another one?
Admit it, you dance in the car.
Oh, I can't use this?
Seriously?
Rude.
Four uses per reset.
Ah.
Does Minda actually drive?
I do.
I have a license.
And I drive.
What did we get?
A trumpet.
Okay.
A license.
We didn't get a hitchhiker this time.
Sad.
Wait, who are you?
Hey, what's up dude?
Glad to see another fellow road tripper out here on the road.
Where are you off to?
What?
What does this mean?
No freaking music.
We are tired.
Let's see.
No, don't get the beer case.
It's a trap.
Do not get the beer case.
It's an absolute trap.
Why does the juice make you tired?
What is it?
A sugar crash maybe?
Wait.
Restores two energy and cures one stack of tired.
Wait, we can get this.
How much is this?
Hold on.
Two dollars?
Yeah, there we go.
That's pretty good actually.
Beer o'clock.
No!
There's not much here, so we can leave.
We can just keep going.
God, that was a big save.
Let's listen to it.
Subject.
Fucking werewolf ass.
Okay.
We'll just shuffle it, you know.
Let's hear it all.
Oh, that's what that means.
Okay, shuffle means all of it.
Having a rough day at work.
No!
Rest in good space.
Recommend Death Road to Canada.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright, play!
It's a little more tame than I expected.
Hey!
Oh, this is...
Oh,
this one is so good!
Is she saying to spread your legs?
I'm in the zone.
Who are you?
Help me out, brother.
I always wanted a brother.
Hitchhiking with my brother.
I've been running for five hours straight.
My legs can't hold me up no more.
I'm innocent.
Wait, what?
You gotta trust me.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
The convict?
I probably shouldn't have acted on the saying, don't judge a book by its cover, when stopped for an escaped prisoner.
But I did.
Besides his stressed out demeanor, there was a cool kindness hiding behind his eyes.
Trust me, bro.
He's 4B.
Hitchhikers won't sit next to the convict.
That's okay, he'll be in the front seat.
Wait, so do we get money every time we use the cash thing?
Do you think, though, if I get pulled over, it's over for me?
Oh, he uses that money!
Oh, hell no.
Wait, seriously?
No.
Cost 10 cash?!
I thought he was gonna rob the people.
Supplies!
We ain't affordin' that.
Hell no.
Time to use my inducted.
Can I
recharge this again?
Don't I have to, like...
I have to go to sleep, right?
I have to rest?
Okay.
Next place we'll rest.
We're hungry and we're tired.
It's okay, we've got...
We've got a hotdog!
What else is here?
We've got food mart, save mart, auto mart.
Okay.
Back it up, back it up, back it up.
Let's get more hotdogs.
This place doesn't sell hotdogs!
Horrible service!
They got some $3 nuts!
Okay, we got chips.
Maybe here, maybe at save mart.
They got some cheese.
6?!
Tuna?
Potato!
You'll need to cook these.
Pizza!
Cowabunga!
Can I sell the trumpet?
Who wants this?
Toilet paper, removes dirty.
Oh, this is good too.
Okay, now we can sleep.
And we'll get a banana.
Oh wait, we have a banana.
We'll get more banana.
Double banana.
Here's hungry, not meant for humans though.
I'm gonna get more...
We'll get more chocolate.
And I'm gonna... What's cheaper?
Chewing gum?
Let's get the cigarettes too.
Sleep!
Good night!
Do I still have my... Oh I'm cold!
Why am I cold?
When you take damage during events, also take 1 durability damage.
Got something hot to drink.
Oh, we gotta get something hot to drink, huh?
Maybe like a coffee?
Maybe here?
Nothing?
Seriously?
Also do I have the... Oh I don't have my flashlight anymore.
I think we should get that too.
Let's see what you got here.
Car upgrade by utility front.
Get a discount.
We currently have the super wide tires, but we don't have any other tires.
That's fine for now, maybe.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O I need a hot drink to go!
Well...
I guess we'll just have to go for it.
I think your ex doesn't mark treasures.
What an interesting band.
Where are we off to?
We can go hiking here!
It's all I've ever wanted.
It's all I've ever wanted to do!
What's this one?
Is that...
Oh, not a shop.
Oh, sleep!
We can sleep here.
No, no, no.
We can go hiking here too.
We can go hiking here!
Try my first chocolate Japanese snack.
That's great.
Would you try?
I'm looking around still.
Hold on.
We can also go hiking here.
Skopolis.
Sorry, I'm not used to the legend yet.
Oh, that's a cafe.
We're gonna have to get work soon too, huh?
Let's see, what's the places with work?
Work, work, work...
This place has...
Work!
Let's go.
Let's go home.
We slept the whole day away and now we're partying at night.
If my brakes break now, I'd be effed.
So effed.
I don't even think this car has airbags.
Our brakes are fine, right?
Test them.
They do feel a bit squishy.
I should get them checked out.
A werewolf!
I should recommend this fan to Bao maybe.
Imagine if she did a cover.
Speed cameras!
It's okay.
It's okay guys.
We're not drunk.
We're not drunk this time.
Follow the rules.
I am, I am, I am.
We're okay.
More attacks this time.
We're fine, we're fine.
We can get through this.
If only I had my lottery ticket.
I know the lottery ticket would have been so good there.
Oh well.
Money threats are really bad in this game.
I can imagine.
Oh, we're more introspection.
I wonder what my parents were doing at my age.
Probably just studying.
I don't think they ever really got a chance to travel much.
It must have been so much easier to go out on a new road trip those days.
Let's say I don't think they really had a chance to travel much.
And we're traveling.
We're living the dream.
Or they just won't tell me about it.
I can imagine it was kind of wild back then.
Are we sad now?
What did I do?
Potholes.
Okay, all threats are set to attack.
Oh, wait.
The duct tape is perfect there.
No, the duct tape.
The duct tape.
There we go.
Nice.
Actually, we can do this one.
Wait, I already listened to this song.
Eject.
I don't really like this one as much.
Let's just shuffle stuff.
Yeah, this works.
Nightlife.
Wait, did it actually pick nightlife?
Introspection.
I'm so happy I fixed the stereo before I left.
Imagine if I had no music.
It's definitely one of the most important things in a road trip.
A hundred percent.
It makes everything cooler.
Inspired.
Next energy cost is reduced to zero.
Lose this when used.
Now we're tired.
We're at our cafe.
Explore?
Wait, can we do that at night?
Maybe that's not wise.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe that's not very wise.
There's like nothing here.
Hmm.
Can I get at the garage?
Oh yeah, we can customize.
Okay, cool.
Oh,
I didn't get anything new, did I?
Dang it.
What's this?
Chocolate.
Oh yeah.
I didn't get anything new.
Are we hungry?
We're tired.
My squishy brakes, how do I fix them?
Oh, repair.
The budget repair is free.
Does it fix brakes?
Rust removal.
None of this says brakes.
Mechanic fun times.
I'm not paying for that.
It's literally free.
Car is already in good enough condition.
Full repair only.
What?
Should we try?
Or was that just an introspection?
Was it just for funsies?
Pay the mechanic.
Are we not needed?
I think so too.
No!
Okay, we'll sleep.
We'll sleep.
We'll work.
We'll explore.
The sun is rising.
We're hungry.
It's okay, we can...
We'll eat a pizza.
Now we're not hungry.
Cowabunga baby!
Choose your own adventure.
Okay, so we can go to the right, which is the important thing.
Or the left, which is the red thing.
Or straight.
See, this has big letters and this has red letters.
I think the red letters might be kind of crazy, right?
Oh, wait.
Oh, just kidding.
It's kind of scary out here.
I'm not going to lie.
Do we have a limited amount of...
What's that sound?
The vines are blocking your way forward.
You light up the cave with your flashlight!
Good thing I got it!
What is that?
What's that sound?
Can I get lost in here?
You found an item!
Return to starting position to claim it.
Okay, what did I find?
This is so scary.
We can't go through the vines.
What's this way?
Can we find other items?
Just go straight.
You found an item!
Nice.
I just stole from an abandoned... question mark?
I found an item!
Okay, this should be good.
I got three things.
I think maybe we can get max...
I actually don't know.
I'm lying.
I have no idea.
Vines are blocking my way forward.
I have to not get lost.
I made it!
You claim the items you are carrying.
Receive all claimed items when you...
Nice!
Okay, okay.
We are losing energy?
Is that what we are losing?
What are we losing?
You used up three energy.
I see.
I think we might have hit the jackpot, baby.
I think we might have hit the jackpot!
Nice, fine.
Let's put our magazines in the backseat.
For nobody to... We'll put them amongst the berries.
We can sell the spilled coffee, I guess.
I don't know.
Jerry can full!
We'll never have to buy gas!
This is great!
And a thermos.
That's huge too.
This run is goated right now.
This is so awesome.
So much free gas!
That was so worth!
New skill tree.
Hiking.
Available for all future playthroughs.
I see.
So these are for...
Right click to see the details.
Gain two armor.
Interesting.
Okay,
let's see.
What is... We can shop here too?
Oh my gosh!
I can get like pie and...
Wow, blueberry pie.
I'm gonna sell the spilled coffee.
Thank you.
I really like the hiking skill, yeah.
Let's see.
How can we make some money here?
Earn extra today.
Become an ad warrior.
You need to drive around with our advert for warrior.
Oh, that's so easy!
We can do that.
Oh my gosh!
We e-toshed our car!
Fardorf.
Our cat Cookie is missing.
Has anyone seen her?
Where's our... Where's our...
Wait, how do I... There we go.
Where are we?
Farsdorf?
Where the hell is that?
Where... Oh, Fardorf!
That's where we are.
No, we are at Honlagrad.
Right?
We need to go to Fardorf.
Oh, I could have just clicked the map.
I'm such an idiot.
That's where we came from.
It's not that far at all.
I think we can do it.
We'll go.
Pizza!
We're short on staff.
And we need someone to deliver pizzas.
In Fardorf?
Actually, we're going there.
Nevermind, we'll accept it.
Oh, we gotta make space.
This is fine.
We have no hitchhikers right now.
A Wraith?
Yarrow, thanks for the Wraith!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
We're playing this game.
We're going to Fardorf.
Yes, Fardorf.
To Fardorf.
Yes!
It's like... Hi Wraithers!
Hello!
This is a roguelike, item management, RPG, road trip game.
Ducky digs for the gift.
And we're just vibing to some good tunes.
And, yeah.
Majestic Falcon?
Are we fighting a bird?
What the hell?
What am I doing?
I'm fighting the bird.
What does this mean?
This threat will give you one random negative status effect.
Perfect.
I think we're good.
It means it doesn't take your resource, but it gives you a debuff.
I see.
We're fine.
We fought the bird and we succeeded, I think.
I think we succeeded.
Introspection.
It feels like some parts of the world have better clouds than others.
I hope I find a place with really big clouds.
Thick, illuminated, majestic.
What did I get for the bird?
Inspired?
Maybe?
I don't know actually.
The best places are always up in the mountains or in the fields.
I want the big cumulonimbus clouds.
You continue driving with a small smile of purpose.
We're in the zone!
Oh my gas!
Guys, we gotta use our jerry can soon maybe.
Big clouds.
Vague lanes.
On the highway?
That seems really bad.
I think we don't want that.
Perfect time for this one.
Good thing we are prepared.
And yes, we are prepared.
My tsikies!
Running out of gas will also do 4 durability damage and make you sad.
Best to fill up... Have you guys ever run out of gas before?
I once did.
I once ran out of gas and a nice lady...
She helped me out.
I like.
Nope, but close.
Forest tranquility?
Why is that a bad thing?
Let's use the duct tape.
Perfect.
We live on E.
No!
I was going up a hill and I ended up...
Running out of gas so it was bad.
Got close a few times.
Living life on the edge.
But I'm not alive so...
Roadkill!
Why did we stop for the roadkill?
Excuse me!
What's wrong with me?
Oh we are dirty!
Because of roadkill.
Because we stopped for the roadkill.
Why did we do that?
Lunch?
Dinner?
No!
What?
Let's clean ourselves up.
Oh wait.
Actually we have no hitchhikers.
I don't care.
Let's remain dirty.
What does the porn magazine do?
Excuse me.
I have an addiction.
I must stop and read the porn on the side of the road.
Found in the forest.
It doesn't do anything?
We are just collecting it?
OK.
I like it.
Missing cat!
Where is my cat?
Did I do it?
Wait, do I need to find the cat?
What?
You got my pizza?
Oh yeah, I do.
I never actually found the cat.
Pizza is my passion in life.
So true.
Oh, I thought the cat was here.
How do I find the cat?
Wait, I'm kind of confused.
Am I dumb?
Maybe that was the roadkill?
No!
No, no, no, no.
You find it randomly in events like the exploration or otherwise.
Beer can.
Why does the ravioli need to be cooked?
It does not.
You can eat it straight from the can.
Let's see.
I have plenty of events there.
Let's get some aspirin.
We have plenty of food so I don't need to get food for a while.
But maybe some chewing gum.
Maybe.
What else is in here?
Right now we can't change our car color.
Because we are in advertisement.
The cat.
So I can't find...
I can't see it.
If I see it, I can't click on it.
Does this...
Wait, does this...
Missing cat.
It doesn't seem...
But it says I returned the cat.
Oh, you can.
The advertisement is a decal.
Oh, OK.
I see, I see.
No, we are not selling the goods.
What are you talking about?
Oh, it's a glitch?
Oh, I see, I see.
It doesn't seem to be a...
Time limit on it.
So I guess we'll go back and go search.
What we can do... Watch this.
Is we go back...
To Honda guide.
And we hike and maybe we'll find him.
Oh yeah, let's refill my gas.
Thank you for the reminder.
Actually, I'm just gonna use the gas station.
Actually, no.
We have so much gas.
Jerry can lol.
Gain 2 gas.
Nah, we're fine.
So we're gonna go back and we're gonna go look, right?
The cat quest has a 9 day limit.
Oh, it does?
Let's go try.
Let's go see if we see him.
Maybe we'll get a hitchhiker this time.
More introspection.
It's wild to think about how many people live and work driving on these roads.
So many people drive such incredibly long commutes for work.
I mean, bless all those truck drivers and bus drivers that drive all around the world.
It must be really cozy at times and really quite lonely as well.
We're inspired.
Let's see if we do the hiking.
Oh, you can't change skills on the road.
Nice.
You say that, but you... I'm not attacking the tractor.
It's attacking me.
I promise.
I'm gonna eat more goldfish, you guys.
While we go over the potholes.
I'm pretty relaxed right now.
I found it on Booth.
I couldn't tell you the store name right now, though.
I'm sorry.
But I think I just searched Sun Hat on Booth.
Oh, our music.
You guys, it's the crack again.
We can't pick up the crack in front of the police.
Right?
That would be so bad.
There's nothing more relaxing than a long drive down a long, empty road once all the noise coming from the trunk stops.
Wait, what?
I'm gonna pick at it.
Lucky.
Plus one durability, baby.
Oh, our music.
Eject.
What's my darling you?
Oh, this one has a lot of songs.
Okay, perfect.
My darling you.
You got that song from being arrested?
Oh yeah, that's right.
We did get this song from being arrested.
Everything alright.
Oh, we're back to the roadkill.
Why are we stopping?
Unlucky.
Oh, threat to attack.
Oh, I can't use this now.
Oh my gosh.
We're in trouble.
Perfect.
I'm trying to get to use the duct tape.
Are we gonna get attacked?
This stupid... We gotta go sleep.
We just stop in the middle of the road for the roadkill.
What the heck did I eat?
I thought it was going to be a tiny one.
What?
Did I just fart?
I'm by myself.
So it's fine.
I gotta take better care of what I eat.
We're satisfied.
What does that give us?
Energy cost decreased by one.
Okay.
One skill point.
Alright, let's open our journal and do the hiking.
Uh...
Game 2.
Oh, that's right.
Oh, we have so much!
Changes targets with current road type.
This one.
Remove all armor.
Destroy one threat for each armor lost.
What?
My armor?
One
threat for each skill used this event.
I'm kinda still confused about the skill trees at the moment.
Still a little trying to learn that at the moment.
I'm going to go hiking.
We're gonna go hiking and then we will...
Alright, let's go find a cat.
And then...
We'll sleep.
Yes!
Alright.
Kitty!
Here, kitty, kitty!
I found an item.
It's a cat.
I promise.
I heard it meow.
Trust.
Trust, it's a cat.
I feel like I'm gonna get lost.
I found a cat!
Trust.
Why is there someone's abandoned car in here?
It's kinda scary.
This area is so spooky.
Three cats, yeah.
We found cats.
Okay.
This way?
Okay, now here's where I'm lost.
There's nothing in here?
Okay, that's fine.
I found another item.
Nice.
I'm lost.
I'm a bit lost.
We're fine.
Are we lost?
No!
Why would you think that?
I know exactly what I'm doing.
I'm here to tell you that I love you very much.
There's a massive blackout in my country.
And I'm spending my last minutes watching your stream.
No!
07.
You can sell this.
Sell this.
None of it was a cat, you guys.
A mushroom.
You found it.
You can put the chewing gum in.
I'm still dirty, but we're okay.
Okay.
Suspension?
Or exhaust pipe?
More scrap?
What do I do with the mushrooms?
I have the most food ever.
You think it'll go bad?
We have this now, the exhaust pipe.
What does this do?
Reduce gas on motorways.
Why not?
And then what was this?
Suspension.
Double the effect of your equipped wheels.
Oh, I can only use one or the other.
Oh no!
Oh, I think this one is better.
I think we should double the effect of our plus one armor.
I believe.
So we'll get plus two armor instead.
Very good.
Sell scrap.
Nice.
What is the point of the bandage?
Remove threat warnings.
That's what it does.
Understood.
I'm going to eat this candy bar.
Just kidding.
I'm going to eat it now.
And then we're going to move this here.
Move it here.
There we go.
The flag uses a utility spot too.
I guess we don't really need it right now, right?
The flag is a discount on gas.
Yeah, so we can change it.
Thank you for letting me know.
Nevermind.
Your thought process was great.
Just the game denied you.
Your purpose.
I don't know guys.
Should we go back to exploring again?
Should we try again?
Try for the cat?
I don't know.
Should we try for the cat?
Looking for an extra...
With a black car.
I can paint my car.
Black car.
In Povil.
Instruments?
We need to get our...
What do you need?
Wait, I have a trumpet!
Urgent help.
My favorite band got stranded without money or gas.
Please bring them some gas.
It's urgent.
We get a skill point.
Google says nothing about the cat sadly.
Let's go one more time.
I'm testing my luck.
I'm testing my luck here.
I actually like this part so much.
It's really fun.
I really like the exploration.
You guys know me.
I love me a good hunt.
I'm gonna get lost.
I'm gonna get lost for sure.
That's okay.
Oh, it's already been looted.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, okay.
So it doesn't... It's not like a new...
Yeah, yeah.
Ah, I see, I see.
Okay.
Nah, man.
Okay, let's go home.
Wait, did I go in here?
Yes.
I'm not lost.
I'm just...
I'm being very thorough.
Oh, shoot.
I'm not lost.
I'm being thorough.
Don't worry about it.
Just being thorough.
Just being extra thorough.
Just being super careful I didn't miss anything.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, see?
I told you guys.
And it's a cat.
It's a different kind of cat.
Guys, we will never be hungry again.
Trust.
We will never go starving ever again.
I can't even fit all these berries.
Eat.
I hope I don't get pulled over.
I'll be really embarrassed.
Never hungry, but plenty thirsty.
And now we can distract the guards.
So true.
We can go hiking here.
Let's go to Skopolis.
And see if we can find the cat there.
Our gas is...
It's okay.
Kinky minky!
Nah, it's just a lewd book.
That's pretty tame, no?
Everybody owns those.
I wanna hitchhike!
I'm lonely!
No, no, no.
No flat tire.
So what does this do?
Gain 2 armor.
How do I use it?
Oh, I forgot to sleep!
It's so over for us.
I forgot to go to sleep.
It's okay.
The armor is tanking it.
All threats to attack!
I really messed up, you guys.
I messed up big time.
We have bandage.
True!
True, true, true.
Give debuff to a 3 random threat.
What?
That was not good.
What's our debuff?
That was close.
Okay.
Night falls.
We gotta go to sleep.
It hit the armor.
That's why I didn't get it.
Yeah, armor!
Hitchhiker!
Hitchhiker, please!
Please, hitchhiker!
Introspection.
Wow, those clouds are incredible!
Looks like some massive Olympian castle.
I gotta stop.
It's strange that I still get moved by something.
What?
No, it's not strange at all.
You decide to stop the car and just watch the clouds go by.
We're inspired!
Oh, what am I doing?
I'm stopping and... Oh, low gas!
It's okay, we got gas.
We got gas, we're okay.
What clouds?
It's like a completely beautiful night.
It's clear.
Weekends!
Man, I don't... I like... I actually really like road trips.
I like road trips so much.
Majestic falcon again.
I like... You know, the journey is part of the fun, no?
I think at least.
Oh, that works.
I'm gonna use my...
It doesn't quite work, but it's fine.
Ouch.
We can just use this twice.
Can't wait to take Minky Plush on road trips with me.
I don't know the last time I've done a road trip though.
Well, my car is not doing so hot, so...
It's not fair.
I've never once won at a carnival or lottery or anything.
Gas prices went up as soon as I decided to get a car.
When I need a mechanic, there's none.
And when I don't, they're everywhere.
The first one is me.
I wonder if most people feel that way.
I got one money!
I got a pity buck.
Let's go.
Then car.
Maybe there's a cat in there.
Give debuff to three random threats.
Why?
Why do you do that?
We're inspired.
It's okay, we can make this easy.
New trait.
Wait.
Oh, experience.
Have a go now has five maximum uses.
A heater!
Scrap.
Okay, let's see.
How do we wanna...
Heater seems pretty big.
I have a lot of berries.
Maybe I don't need so many berries.
Right?
Oh, fold the seeds.
I need my berries.
We haven't come across a single person, so why not, right?
We can just eat a bunch of berries.
Your thumbnail is too cute.
I got you whacked enough.
You guys like sundresses that much?
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, we're here.
New skill tree, driving.
Let's go.
Basic targeting skill.
Cost one gas.
No.
Cost one energy.
Wait.
If you get it perfect with this skill, gain one gas.
The skill trees, you guys.
I'm stupid with these.
I don't understand them at all.
Wisps being unwise.
That's okay.
Oh, hello.
Nice ride, kid.
Heard about the great race down at the Pine Raceway?
You should check it out.
New journey.
The great race.
Warm welcome to the annual weekend long driving competition at Pine Raceway.
We would never win this.
Install a roll cage.
Get to the race.
Enter the race.
Big first place prize?
I can't not accept it, so...
Okay.
Oh, we're kind of close.
Actually.
Okay.
Interesting.
Alright, first things, we're going to sleep.
Stay until morning.
It's so expensive.
But we'll get a nice sleep, right?
It will cure us of all our ailments, probably.
Everything is... Wow.
We're happy and we are satisfied.
There is countless memes and posts about guys going feral for sundresses.
Seriously?
I never knew that.
Why is there no grocery store here?
Hey mister, you need some berries?
Customize.
Oh no!
We can either get two max durability or we can get the heater.
We can't have both.
What do you guys think?
Sundresses are cute?
I see.
I learned something today.
A sundress killed my father.
Isn't it summer?
But we were cold earlier, no?
We had the cold...
We got cold earlier.
Why are these woods so terrifying?
Wait.
Ok, just kidding.
Hopefully it's not just mushrooms.
Hopefully there is also a cat in there.
I had a road trip a while back with a few friends to pick up a puppy in New York.
We sang the musical for Hamilton.
All the way there and back.
Great times.
I still haven't seen Hamilton.
Hamilton, Hamilton, Hamilton, Hamilton.
My name is Hamilton.
Mom, I really am a 10.
Everybody knows about this ham I spin.
Hamilton, Hamilton.
Big trees here.
Oh gosh, scared me.
Maybe I got everything in here.
Watch along?
Where can you watch it?
You guys think I got everything in here?
I feel like I didn't miss anything.
The car is down behind me.
It wasn't very big in here, I think.
Oh wait, a second cave?
Just kidding, I did not get everything.
I'm a liar.
I actually don't know where I'm going at all.
There we go.
Okay.
More scrap to sell.
We can sell this immediately.
What do we do with the mushroom?
These are different kind of mushroom we don't have yet.
There we go.
A fender and a radiator.
Negates the hot status.
Yes.
Okay.
We're good.
I guess you could sell the mushroom.
Yes.
That's fine.
I guess we could.
So let's see, what do we do with these guys?
This is a utility.
Okay, negates the hot status, increases durability.
That's big.
We need more durability.
More health, please.
Hmm...
We don't have anything for the roof yet.
Or the engine.
Okay.
Oh wait, I was going to sell the scrap.
Sell scrap, sell scrap, sell scrap, sell scrap.
Cool.
Saltyfish, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Yeah, we'll save the radiator for now.
I mean, I have the heater also.
So we have one for heat and one for cold.
Honestly, we're so good.
We have hot and cold.
So you're hot, then you're cold.
You're yes, then you're no.
You're in, then you're out.
Up, then you're down.
Where are we going from here?
We're good on money, which is kind of crazy.
We're actually so good on money.
What place has a thrift store?
Nowhere around here.
We can keep exploring.
We can go to Lawnery.
Nochi, thank you so much for the five gifts.
Thank you.
There was one more scrap there, what?
Did I miss it?
Oh, I missed this one.
Thank you.
I also realized I have two aspirins.
I could probably sell the trumpet too, but...
Whatever.
Hot and cold, Minky.
Loner Larry.
Lawnery.
Let's go.
Oh, I just realized our toons.
Shuffle baby, shuffle.
Oh, my mouse just died.
Hold on.
I got to plug it in.
I can't press play.
It was blinking.
It was yelling at me like, hey plug me in.
Okay.
Yes.
Okay, we're good.
Low gas!
We're all good.
Everything's fine.
Crystal boys.
Roadkill.
When are we going to get a dang hitchhiker?
Game hates me.
What is this?
Nothing happened.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, I think my chat died.
Give me one second, you guys.
I will bring you back to life.
One second.
YouTube bros.
You're dead.
Just like me.
Oh,
my gosh.
I just realized the time too.
No, but I want to keep playing.
I haven't made my zort fighting room.
Wait!
No!
Did I forget saying bye to my best friend turning off the oven?
No, no.
I'll say the best friend.
No, we said bye a few days ago.
Oh, we're so sure.
Hitchhikers level faster.
If I had any.
Do it on stream?
Okay.
Something on the roadside.
Gonna miss the collab tonight, so this is my last Minto stream before your break.
Have lots of fun in Japan.
Thanks, Nashi!
Thank you, thank you.
Whatever this is, is dangerous.
Watch this god play.
I messed up.
Nevermind.
Did you think there was a person in there?
Oh, my god!
We found the cat!
We found the cat.
Let's go!
Turn this car around!
Hot holes.
Schrodinger's cat reel.
Turn this car around!
Oh, my goodness.
It's trying to kill me.
It's threatening.
It's threatening me.
Wait, is this a... Okay, I have one last thing.
So next time we'll have to sleep.
We'll have to...
Name the cat?
It's not ours.
We're gonna go return him.
I'll name him Minto Jr. No.
I'll name him...
Thunder Breaker.
Unlucky.
Wait, what's happening?
Is it just wind?
Oh, insect swarm?
Okay.
Oh, no!
This is not good.
Ouch!
Oh, ouch!
Am I in the zone?
Oh, escape.
Yeah, I think we could...
Oh, I forgot that that's an option.
Which one is it again?
Oh, wait.
Not that.
It's this one, right?
We tanked it.
I see.
Use during events to escape or skip the...
Yeah,
that hurt though.
That hurt pretty bad.
Welcome to Lonery, everybody.
Let's see what we got here.
My favorite band.
Oh, the band.
No, I gotta go return the cat.
I don't need food.
I can sell the cat!
He gives me 2k.
That's so sad.
We are hungry, right?
Oh, we're just tired.
Yeah, but we are hungry.
Which we have plenty of.
Oh yeah, we're good now.
But we're also tired.
So let's rest here.
I was really hoping this would be your kind of game.
I'd love a weekend road trip again in the future.
Yeah, I mean...
We're definitely probably not gonna get to the...
Festival today.
But we have to get to the festival.
No.
We have to get to the festival.
I'm gonna get this multispray.
Since I have nothing for blue.
At the moment.
Alright.
Turn this car around!
We gotta go to...
Far.
Fardorf.
It is truly far.
Oh gosh.
How about we go...
Here.
And here here.
Might be our best bet.
Far far away.
And then once I...
Once I deliver the cat...
We'll call it there.
What
am I doing?
Shouldn't I be looking for a job or something?
No!
It's the time for adventure!
Kind of helps.
The cat is like jamming in the backseat.
Oh my gosh, my car though.
We've taken a lot of damage.
Oh my gosh!
Our first hitchhiker!
In the middle of the night.
Who are you?
Good thing you came along.
I was thinking I was gonna miss the show.
I'm headed to the big effing apple.
Hey, do you have some food with you?
I think she's hungry.
Who is she?
He has a dog?
This kid was just standing on the side of the road with his dog.
A pure breed boarzoi!
I couldn't even tell he was looking for a ride.
It doesn't pay to try.
It was written on one of his pins.
He looked a bit like a junkie.
Needs extra space in the car.
Uh oh, are they gonna fight?
That's our first hitchhiker though.
You will need extra space for the dog.
Yes, I do have space.
How big is this dog?
He needs a seat.
Oh my god!
I guess we'll try hanging out with him.
I guess.
Oh, the punk.
Oh my god, the dog is in the backseat.
No one would pick me up with my dog.
Appreciate it.
Oh my god, another hitchhiker.
Wait, hitchhiker argument?
What are you talking about?
We have one.
Who is he arguing?
Oh, are we arguing with him?
Oh my god.
Stop it!
With the dog.
You finished advertised.
Oh nice, we got a lot of money there.
I'm currently tired.
Can we go exploring at night?
I should be really discouraged, no?
Let's try it, let's try it.
Oh, I don't like that.
This should be highly... I feel like I'm about to be chased after by a serial killer or something.
Oh my god, it's scary.
This is so scary!
Minus one.
I think I just went in a circle.
And this...
Big rock is blocking.
Oh, not
yet.
What was that sound?
I'm gonna get eaten here, aren't I?
Vines.
I'm not lost.
I'm just trying to find other places.
Minus one.
There's not much in here, honestly.
Let's just leave.
We're losing a lot of energy actually, being in here.
Why?
Okay.
We got some matches.
Might not always work.
And cigarettes.
And trash.
Let's sell that.
More cigarettes.
Ours is pretty full right now, so we'll put the matches, I suppose, and hope that they work.
And enter.
And sleep.
What is the hitchhiker's... Where does he sleep with his dog?
I'm not paying for him too, right?
Yeah!
Alright!
Where to?
Road map.
We said we were going to go to...
Oh, I just noticed there's...
We should be fine.
Gosh, we have a long drive, don't we?
Yeah.
It would have been the same even if we went this way, though.
So it's okay.
My gas.
We'll use it.
The gas, we're okay.
We still have another full can.
And I think we can...
Probably...
We can probably fill those up, even.
Can you sell the hitchhiker and their dog?
I wish.
I knew some guys that played in a band that sounded a bit like this.
Oh, I believe it.
Their biggest gig was to their moms.
We're gonna get this cat home safe and sound!
Trust.
I should think of something to think.
Do not think.
Not as easy as I thought.
Oh, it's raining!
Thunderstorm!
Head empty.
Give shields the one random threat.
Shield?
Look at the dog!
He doesn't do anything!
Removes three random threats.
Do it.
Even with the shield!
Damn, that's actually pretty good, not gonna lie.
Boarzoi.
He's a good guy.
He's a good boy.
Oh, I should have used the...
Dang it, I didn't think about it.
It's okay.
Happy turn!
Happy!
Use crafty items.
New trait.
Wait, did I not use that?
Didn't I do it for you?
Fallen tree!
Rough terrain.
Let's use it on this.
What does the shield do though?
Let me try it.
Oh, I see.
You gotta get it twice.
Okay, okay.
I learned.
Add one durability threat.
No!
How many times has Minto been pulled over?
Zero?
The forest is inspiring.
We're still happy.
Oh my gosh.
I still have three out of four.
We can use it.
Yay!
I only got pulled over that one time!
The forest line looks like a bunch of teeth.
Minus half.
We're not happy anymore.
We have to spend our days with this bozo.
The dog is cute at least.
At least the dog is good.
Can I not fill up the jerry cans?
36 dollars even.
Let's do like 15.
Dang it.
Good enough.
I thought so, but I think I was wrong.
Someone said you can't.
Oh no!
A poor cat will be returned half deaf from blasting music.
Don't say that!
Who are you?
Hey!
Good seeing ya.
I drove past a really freaking crazy party up in the hills.
So weird.
It was dead quiet, then all of a sudden...
Bam!
Party!
Why is my thing like kind of weird?
Naked dude climbing a tree and some girls doing coke in an outdoor jacuzzi.
Fun stuff.
If we tried for the rehab route...
Oh my gosh.
It's craziness out there everybody.
The dog is staring at me.
It's freaking me out.
I don't think I need anything honestly.
I guess, what, do I have to sell the jerry cans?
But they don't give me any money.
A can gives me more money than the empty jerry can.
Sell the berries?
I have a lot of money.
I don't need that.
They are only 50 cents.
I guess we'll keep going.
Or rather...
37 dollars.
No,
it doesn't let you refill.
So honestly, just getting rid of them is the best case.
What the trumpet do.
It's very nice and clean.
And...
Alright, let's get to the cat.
We're almost there.
Sorry, I'm looking around because I'm like...
There's another... Wait.
Oh my gosh, I totally...
We went the long way.
Dang it, I didn't realize there was a second place.
Can I just skip it?
Oh well.
Okay, let's go.
Come on!
I misread the map entirely.
We went the nice way.
Sell the dog.
What year is this game taking place in?
It says early 2000s.
Behind large truck.
I hate that.
Alright, give shield to one random threat.
Okay.
Alright, watch this.
And then...
Ouch,
threat please.
We are so close to this truck.
We have a death wish.
Damn it, why did I do that?
Oh, I have an extra turn.
I think I just ran out of these.
No, I'm stressed.
I am stressed!
Yeah, maybe stop following behind so hard.
I'm stressed!
Nice.
Wait, did it work?
I don't think it did.
This game.
More attacks this turn.
Okay, we just gotta get rid of them.
Perfect.
Yeah, we got rid of stress.
Let's try using the matches again.
Matches please.
Why doesn't it work?
That's the third time I've used these stinking matches and they don't work every time.
Guys, we are gonna run out of...
Step on it!
I have to.
I had to.
Yikes.
Come on.
I'm gonna kick this guy out of my car.
I've never had a hitchhiker argument before.
Excuse me.
Why are we fighting?
Next turn.
Raiders.
Oh, thank you for the raid.
Sorry, I didn't see who raided me.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Murphy, thanks for the gifted.
We don't have vibes right now.
We have only stress.
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Please, take me home.
Oh gosh, why is this road so long?
Ok, phew.
It's just introspection.
That driver must be like 14.
No way he could have a license.
I'm so happy I don't have pimples like that anymore.
Feel your face, touch your brow and the crease of your nostril.
What?
What does that mean?
Why are we feeling our face?
Can't tell if I'm greasy or just sweaty.
We're hot.
And we're hungry.
It's ok.
We can fix it.
Hungry?
No problem.
Minus hunger.
And we can negate the hot status if this place has a... It does not.
Awesome.
Beep boop.
I wanna sell the matches cause they suck.
You know what?
I am.
Screw the matches.
Don't like them.
They have never helped me.
Let's do...
There's no gas ones in here.
Let's do the duct tape.
Let's buy the duct tape.
Mao Mao, thank you so much for the time gifted.
Hope you like berries.
What's the point of buying food if all you need is berries?
If you can just get berries from the wild, why would you buy anything else?
Why would you buy chips?
Why would you buy anything?
Why?
Let's rest.
We gotta get this cat home.
We're not hot anymore.
My car.
You can repair durability at garages.
Maybe there's a garage in the next place.
Oh, there is!
Okay, nice.
We'll repair.
But first, we must get there.
Berries tend to go bad.
Not in this game, I guess.
Especially...
Just, you know, they're just out in my car.
They're totally fine.
Muddy road.
Oh, I forgot about CDs.
Sorry guys, I completely forgot about our music.
Okay, we've got this.
Let's use this can.
My can, please.
Can.
Nice.
And you.
Perfect.
I can't believe that gives us damage.
The forest is inspiring.
You, and then one more.
Thank you.
A hitchhiker also has abilities.
That's right.
I keep forgetting.
Besides his little skill that he gives me.
We're getting dirty.
Our car is getting pretty muddy.
Nasty.
Distracted.
Me?
I'm distracted by what?
Rough terrain?
Wait, what am I doing?
What is... Let's see.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Remove a random threat.
Screw it.
It's worth.
Oh, my gas is low.
Maybe it wasn't worth.
What does the dog do?
Nothing.
It's OK.
We're out.
The dog gives motivation.
What just happened?
The punk has reached level 2.
Let's go, punk.
I think we'll have enough gas until the next place probably.
Behind large truck.
Get me out of here.
OK, give shield.
Why are the enemies getting so tough all of a sudden?
Use mechanic related items.
We got a new trait.
Mechanic.
Get better prices at garages.
OK, let's go.
No.
OK.
We're stressed.
No, we're stressed.
OK, this could be worse.
Perfect.
OK, it could be worse.
It could be worse.
All hitchhikers are asleep.
Oh, my god.
We're fine.
Probably.
It kind of was a waste, but that's fine.
Why don't I get any of the social ones anymore?
New journey inheritance.
This is your grandmother's physician.
There's no easy way...
The timing.
Oh, the timing.
The cancer has completely metastasized and she is left with only a couple days left before total body failure.
Come by the treatment center as soon as you can.
My condolences.
Don't take any durability.
Good driver.
Drive faster.
OK, let's go.
I can't read the train.
Or I can't... I don't know what it said.
We have to get all the way over there?
There's no way.
Grandma's dying.
Is there a gas station here?
There is not.
Oh, it's closed.
That's OK.
We have to rest anyway.
Why are we tired?
We just rested.
It's still closed.
And we're cold.
Is this closed?
No.
Repair, please.
We'll do a full repair.
Yeah, I would get more jerrycans, but...
Oh wait, we can buy this one at least.
Yeah, I'm gonna buy it.
Well, it's so expensive.
No, I'll save it.
I'll save.
What's in here?
Exploring the open world.
Stretching my legs a little bit.
Explore.
There's a rock in my way.
Is there anything in here for me to take?
A spooky cave.
We got some mushrooms.
Probably.
What else is in here?
The rock.
I hope there's monsters in some of these.
I sure hope not.
What do you think?
We're back at the beginning.
Did I go every way?
Maybe I did.
No?
Maybe I didn't?
I can't tell.
Oh, we found more?
Let's go.
Come on, give me an abandoned tent.
Give me some of the good stuff.
Give me the magazines.
Give me some coins.
Sometimes though I think the little water droplets are something spooky.
Oops, mushrooms.
You know what?
I'm gonna go sell them.
I'm gonna sell the mushrooms.
We'll take them and we'll sell them.
All of them.
I miss Mito.
She's gone to Japan for so long.
No, I'm right here!
Enter.
Still closed?
Ok, we'll sleep.
Now it's open.
We're still cold.
This is a cafe!
It is not a store.
Oh my gosh.
Oops.
Deliver some boxes.
We can get a hot drink.
Actually, wait, I can sell them here.
When I close my eyes it's like she's speaking to us.
I'm talking to you!
Oops.
Now we're not cold anymore.
Cinnabon.
I'm starting to get hungry.
I should eat before... before collab.
I wanna keep playing this though.
Oh my gosh, it's kind of addicting.
It's kind of really addicting.
Oh no.
Alright, alright, alright.
But we gotta get to the cat.
We gotta get the cat home.
We're so close.
Next!
Next stop.
To Fardorf!
Away!
I'm losing... Hold on.
I'm losing Mito and all of Holo Oshis for a month.
A month?
I'm not gonna be gone for a month.
What are you talking about?
I'm gone for a week.
C-E-X-69-9 Oh man, too good.
I'd be so embarrassed with that license plate.
Oh man, too good.
I wish mine was better.
What's wrong?
Oh no, we're hungry!
How did I not notice?
Time for berries.
Alright, on the road again.
A year without Minky?
No!
I'm right here.
Near Dorf, Fardorf, wherever you are, Dorf.
I like how I'm still using this energy drink.
Itasha.
I don't think this lady has brought us any luck.
I don't think she's a lady luck after all.
Majestic Falcon!
Perfect.
Guess we'll just get rid of one.
Heavy rain, add one durability threat.
No!
Oh come on.
Perfect.
Oh, extra turn, let's use the cigarettes.
Nice.
Road phase, give debuff to 3 random threat.
Alright, threat averted.
Goodbye Majestic Eagle Falcon.
Oh, my iTunes!
How could I forget?
Sorry guys, we've been trackless for so long.
Tailgating car!
I hope you enjoy the collab in Japan.
Have fun with your first cafe collab.
By the way, I'm glad you like the Arctic Mission artist.
Oh, thanks Mirrorlit!
Oh my gosh!
This guy is an asshole.
Thank you for the pink by the way.
I appreciate it.
Oh my god!
He's honking at me!
All threat to attack.
Unlucky.
How do we keep getting unlucky?
We're supposed to have a hula lady.
The driving test really don't prepare you for how many birds you have to fight.
It's true.
If you brake and he hits you, you get the money.
So honestly, it's like a win to me, baby.
I like this West Coast band.
Oh, no car holes.
Yeah, it's his fault.
I kind of wish someone would hit me so I could get a new car.
I kind of wish that...
You know, someone would hit me.
And then I could...
Oh, whoops, wrong one.
I could get the money.
It'd be kind of nice, I'm not gonna lie.
Okay.
Ouch.
Alright, Minto, buckle up.
Yeah.
15 minutes to collab?
Oh, shit!
Oh, I think they're messaging me.
Wait.
Oh, introspection.
Sorry, I was reading.
I had a lot of DMs.
Introspection.
Jeez, this road is really boring.
Look out the door.
No, keep your eyes on the road.
Not a bend or curve or even some nice nature.
There's nature everywhere.
What are you talking about?
Oh, we're tired.
Look out the window.
Do it.
Here!
Lady, your cat!
You found... She's been standing out here for days, even in the rain.
Oh my god!
We got a hundred dollars!
She's my best friend!
Ah!
We did it, baby!
We did it!
A toolbox.
Oh, nice.
You know what?
This jerrycan is less expensive.
Let's get it.
Were we cold earlier?
No, we were hot earlier.
Now we're tired.
Alright.
What a deal.
Chicken wings!
You're starving?
You can get that bad?
That doesn't sound so good.
Let's get some... We don't need the soap because we still have the toilet paper.
We still have a good amount of cigarettes.
Beans.
What's this one?
Toilet paper.
Oh, we got more toilet paper.
No, back it up, back it up.
Any hotdogs?
Nothing of the sort.
No hotdogs.
I'm gonna fill up my gas.
Let's see.
Let's get to like...
You know what?
We did good.
We deserve a full tank of gas.
We deserve a full tank of gas, baby.
And with that, I'm gonna go make a waiting room for my next collab in 10 minutes.
I have to install the game.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys!
Otsumito!
Here.
Actually, while I'm here, let me just make the thumbnail.
Zort.
Zort game.
Let's see.
Actually, we'll listen to the music, you know?
What the heck is this game?
Oh, this is Doki's suggestion by the way, so...
I don't know what this is.
Zort.
I'm making a thumbnail right now.
This game is so fun though.
I wanna keep driving.
Get it?
That's the name of the game.
That's the name of the game, baby.
Title drop.
Roll credits.
Otsumito, everybody!
Thank you so much!
I'll see you guys if you come to the collab, and if not, I'll see you later.
I'll see you when I'm back from Japan!
Otsumito!
And if I see you at the collaboration cafe...
Take lots of pictures, okay?
Or you'll see me on Twitter too, you know?
I'll be posting, of course, obviously.
Bye bye!